[APPLAUSE]
JAKOB KALBFELL:
Thank you very much.
Welcome everybody to
our very own sauna here.
Bear with me for this
second last question
of the day, which is about
a kind of important topic.
It's about the Holy
Grail of app developers,
because it's about revenues.
And if it's about revenues,
it's about money that
will make your business grow.
So we do the good
old hands up game one
more time just to keep you a
bit moving after the break.
Hands up if you optimize and
measure lifetime value already.
That's not-- that's
like 20% maybe.
Out of those--
keep your hands up.
Out of those who measure
and optimize lifetime value
already, how many of you would
say you do it really well
and you wouldn't change
a thing if you could.
Oh, OK.
I think we haven't had
that in London or Paris.
So that's 0% of
the audience, which
in turn means the presentation
is highly relevant.
So that's good.
Lifetime value in the apps
world is quite a heavy topic,
especially in the
late afternoon hours.
We're going to try to get it
to you with this structure.
First of all, a little bit
like in driving school,
we're going to go into the
theoretical foundations
of lifetime value modeling
and of predictive analysis.
And secondly, we're going to
go into a bit more practical
perspective, applying
your theoretical knowledge
and going into best practices
that you can actually
use in your own businesses.
Now, let's start directly
with the first part.
Predictive analysis is
the underlying theory
that helps you answer any kind
of question you ask yourself
about the future
of your business.
It helps you answer or to
prove any kind of hypothesis
right or wrong.
So predictive analysis
is really a theory.
Lifetime value is a part of
this theory, but by far not
the only one.
Now, it enables you to
forecast users' behavior.
And as you can see
on the slide here,
this woman seems to
have a retail shop.
So she's asking herself
what products should I
put in my shop.
Where should I put the
products in my shop?
How many products
should I put in my shop?
How frequent will
users or buyers
come to my shop
and purchase goods?
What's the cost of acquiring
customers to my shop?
And what's the lifetime
value of my users in my shop?
Now, for predictive analysis,
there are very simple models
that you can apply to
answer those business
critical questions, and
there are very complex ones.
Simple models could
really be let's
say you have a social app,
and you're asking a specialist
to give you an analysis of how
much revenue you could actually
make using ad monetization.
That's fairly
simple and helps you
understand that
question or to give
the answer to that question.
There are also extremely
complex models, some of which
are really higher maths.
So I'm not going to go
in-depth into those.
But be aware that
some structures like
Pareto, net by nominal
value, and so on could
be important here.
If you want to read up on that,
please feel free to do so.
To run predictive analysis,
who would have thought so?
We need data.
And if we want
data, we need tools.
So if you want to answer
those business questions,
you have to be able to
put the right data in.
There are three things
to remember here.
First of all, choose
the right metrics.
Comes kind of obvious.
Typical metrics would be
engagement data, retention
data, like Nico and Maxine
talked about before.
Number of active users
you might be expecting,
frequency of visits,
recency of the last purchase
or the last visit, and
so on and so forth.
Make sure that you
put the variables that
answer the question.
Secondly, the importance
of those variables
that you're feeding
into the data models
actually depends on
several questions.
First of all, type of the app.
If you're a social app,
you care about engagement.
Whereas if you're
a real estate app,
you assume that engagement
is kind of cyclical.
So users will only look
for apartments or houses
in a very, very few months
of a year or of a decade.
Lastly, depending on
the analytical model
that you're actually using,
importance very as well.
So if you're using a very
complex mathematical model,
you will need a lot
more data than if you're
using a simple one.
Also the treatment of data
and the ability of your tool
to process it is
highly important.
So it has to be able
to import data quickly.
It has to be able to
cluster it according
to the question or the
hypothesis you're feeding in.
And it has to be able to treat
the data quickly and give
the output to you as
soon as you need it.
So That's data.
Predictive analysis,
however doesn't only
depend on the data you have
from your analytical tools.
It also depends on some
contextual factors.
One example being, do you have a
contractual or a noncontractual
relationship to your user?
A contractual relationship
could be your electricity bill.
Or it could be a
subscription in a news app.
That's contractual relationship.
It gives you already
the lifetime of how long
will you get your fees or the
money you charge from the user.
Whereas a
noncontractual, the user
can just bounce or churn
whenever he or she wants to.
Stop playing a game, stop buying
your retail app, and so on.
So this factor will
obviously influence
the predictive analysis
as soon as you're talking
about for instance revenues.
Also, predictive
analysis will be
influenced by the stage
in which you're in.
So if you're a startup, and
you're very new to the market,
you have to persuade
a lot of people
that your startup is
actually a good idea.
Investors, stakeholders,
your users, and so on.
So you might make more
aggressive assumptions.
That will reflect in your
predictive analysis model.
If you're a mature
business, you've
been around for a couple of
years, you know your market,
you know your
users, you will take
more conservative assumptions.
That also influences.
Now like I said in the
beginning, predictive analysis,
that's just a theory because
it underlies lifetime value.
It's the theory on
which this built.
Why are we talking
about lifetime value?
Why are we giving 45 minutes
of our time to lifetime value?
And why is it the last
session of the day?
Well, because it's
really important.
So that's why you need to give
me your last bit of attention
that you're having.
Lifetime value makes
you understand the value
that users have for you.
It makes you understand
what revenue you
will generate in the future.
It makes you understand which
channels are the right channels
to invest in.
Where should you
put your resources.
And what's actually
going to be the outcome.
What's going to be the
dividend for yourself
or for your investors?
Those questions can give
you a whole lot of answers.
A popular example is many
newspaper apps ask me
should we invest in mobile web
or should we invest in apps?
Well essentially, you should
think about lifetime value.
It will help you.
It's one of the metrics, but
it's a good one to look at.
If you calculate lifetime
value, there are some pitfalls
and I wanted to point them
out before we actually
go into the math itself.
First of all, make sure your
growth strategy is not just
focused on maximizing
lifetime value.
Like I said, it's one metric.
But it should be rather
an effect than a cause.
So lifetime value,
if it increases,
it should be the
result of actions
that you take on your
product, on your marketing
strategy and your
communication strategy,
and so on and so forth.
Lifetime value should also not
be your competitive advantage.
Let's assume you
have a lifetime value
of $100, and your competitor,
why ever you know that has $50.
Don't get lazy on that because
it's a temporary snapshot.
So if you get lazy in the higher
lifetime value you get, and you
don't continue to
develop for your users,
this might have
bad repercussions.
A second point is a too
optimistic lifetime value
would lead you to an
excess in investment.
And we all know what it means.
That means you go
into the red numbers.
Remember lifetime value
is based on assumptions.
So assumptions can be wrong.
And so a lifetime value
shouldn't be the only criteria,
and you should look
into different scenarios
and how to calculate it.
Conservative versus aggressive.
Let's make an example of
cost of acquiring customers.
In theory, the cost
of acquiring customers
could be equal to
lifetime value.
If it's higher, you're
in the red numbers,
which is a bad sign.
Only very few investors
actually allow that if it's
your growth strategy.
A rule of thumb that was
told to us is 30% to 40%
of your lifetime value should
be the maximum that you spend
on custom acquisition costs.
Now we get to the
calculation later.
And there are some other
things to look out for,
but that's the basic assumption.
That's the rule of thumb.
Maths.
So the formula you
see here is the basis
of every other
lifetime value formula
you're going to find around.
Lifetime value depends
on engagement, retention,
monetization.
I think it was Maxine who had
that on his slides as well.
So he took my message
away, but it's true.
It depends on those
three variables.
Lifetime value, for
a certain period,
equals lifetime times
average revenues per user.
Sounds very simple.
Now let's look into the
different variables.
First, the lifetime
value period.
So the lifetime
value you're going
to get out of your
equations will heavily
depend on the time frame
for which you calculated.
A user that has a certain
lifetime value for 180 days
LTV calculation we have a very
different value for a 365 day
lifetime period calculation.
What factors influence your
lifetime period decision?
Sorry, I'm going to say
LTV, because I'm really
too lazy to say lifetime
value every time.
So what factors influence this?
First of all, the
business nature.
Is your business nature
long or is it shorter?
Is it an Olympic Games, which
is relevant for a couple
of months, or is it in a
software as a service business,
which users might be
using for years and years?
Secondly, business model.
Advertising, non contextual
business model, subscriptions,
contextual business model.
You'll choose a different
[INAUDIBLE] or period.
And stage of company,
again will influence that.
So startups tend to make
aggressive assumptions,
so they go for a
longer lifecycle.
Mature businesses would
go for a shorter one.
La Matinale, on this example
has an average lifetime
of their subscriptions
of 15 months.
So that's the lifetime
variable, not the period.
However, they decided
to calculate the period
for one and for two years.
Why do they do that?
Because they want to
see how the numbers
change between those two models.
They funnel it together.
They look at the aggregate,
and they take decisions
based on the two
isolated to each other.
That's for them to understand
how it actually differs.
That's a nice example here.
Lifetime calculation.
Now, this curve.
The retention, the
survival curve.
So for lifetime,
retention is critical.
Because it essentially
tells you the opportunities
that you have to convert
a user into a pay user.
So lifetimes also highly
correlated to engagement.
Because the more engaged
the user is, the more likely
he is to reach to be retained,
the more lifetime he will have.
Again, there are very different
ways of calculating lifetime.
Some very simple ones and
some very complex ones.
We heard that before I, know.
First, for the simple
model for instance,
you would define
a moment of churn.
When is churn actually
happening for you?
Let's say you say if a
user is two weeks inactive,
he's turned that's
my definition of it.
Let's say you look
at your curves,
and you find out
well on average,
after six months that's when
users are getting inactive.
Hence, that's my churn.
And hence that's my
average lifetime.
Now there are also
very complex ones
which are based on
those survival curves.
We're going to get to
that later, I promise.
Lastly, our monetization
metric where prices come in.
Average revenue per user.
Now that's typically not
that difficult to determine
because it's usually total
monthly revenues divided
by monthly active users.
Giving you the average
revenues per month.
Make sure that you're
taking the right units.
So you should have the
same units then when
you do lifetime calculation.
That's the basic
calculation of it.
Now you might ask--
I have to drink in
between because otherwise
I can't bear it.
You might ask
yourself, what's cost?
What about cost?
Many developers in fact,
don't only look at revenues,
they do look at costs as well.
Because in real life you want
to know how your net lifetime
value actually looks like.
So what you would do is
typically top down method,
you take the revenue you earned,
you deduct all variable costs,
and you get into
variable contribution.
So be aware that variable
contribution can vary
for different user segments.
And that's something
also to look at.
Obviously, the more user
segments you define,
and for the more
user segments you
make this analysis,
the more tricky
it will be in the end to
calculate your lifetime value.
But it's worth it.
Also you might ask yourself,
well if I am a very long cycle
app, how should I do it
with future revenues that
occur far out in the future?
That's when the
discount rate comes in.
So like some of you might
have learned in investment
calculations, you
discount future cash flows
into net present value.
So that's very important because
if you think about the example,
if you have 10 euros
today, those 10 euros
won't buy you the same amount of
goods in five years, inflation.
So that's something to take
into consideration here,
because your investments
today will be impacted
by those revenues tomorrow.
In the best case scenario,
it would be refinanced.
That's something to take
into account as well.
So that's it for the theory.
Like I said in the introduction,
we will take the theory first.
And we will then apply
it into practice.
Now as you see, I am a
passionate motor biker.
You can see that here.
I'm a very passionate
motorbiker.
And together with
some of my biker pals,
we came up with the
idea to develop an app,
specifically for motorbikers.
We want to showcase the
nicest routes across Europe,
the nicest hotels,
the best places
to drink your non-alcoholic
beers with your biker pals.
So we came up with
this app idea.
And we're
bootstrapping this app.
Hence, we want to
know what's going
to happen with our investment.
And how can we refinance it
and where should we invest it.
So in order to determine which
monetization model we choose,
we talked to some contacts
we have across the industry,
and we wanted to figure
out how they do it
with their LTV calculations.
First of all, we found that it's
essentially four pure business
models and many hybrid
business models prevailing
in the industry.
You have premium apps,
you have subscriptions,
you have in-app purchases
of freemium, you have ads,
and you have hybrid models.
In reality, hybrid models
are the most common ones
in the industry.
Let's start with premium.
The good news is
premium is the easiest
to calculate lifetime value
because your LTV essentially
equals the price.
Now the user acquisition
costs also tend
to be very accurately calculated
because you can just base it
on the LTV you're having,
or best case scenario
on the net LTV [INAUDIBLE].
Now that being said,
that is a priori.
It means usually you
will have hybrid models
especially with premium.
We talked to some
contacts at Cameringo.
And they're one of the
most popular photography
apps in Play.
So they're having a
premium business model.
And they told us that the
price is the key for them
and the price has to be right.
You have to be able to offer the
user the exact price point he
or she is willing to buy.
They're doing loads of testing
around these two pounds
99 using price elasticity
testing methods,
using indices like the Big Mac
Index or certain purchasing
power indexes in order
to set the right price.
Also, for Cameringo
when it comes
to maximizing lifetime
value, they're
looking into two main things,
store ratings and reviews,
and story listing.
We heard a lot about those
topics already today,
but this actually confirms it.
If the moment of truth
comes, and the user
is supposed to buy in
your app, before he's ever
seen it or seen
anything that maybe
a promotional video
or a screenshots,
you have to have good ratings,
even more than any other model.
And you have to have reviews
that give direct feedback.
The best camera app
out there, period.
I've tried them all.
Go ahead, buy it.
You like it.
So they need those
kind of reviews
because that's the word
of mouth that you need.
So what are they
doing to optimize it?
First of all, they are super
protective with custom service.
It goes without saying they're
responding to bad reviews.
They're also responding
to good reviews.
But they're actionally it.
That's tricky.
So that means whenever they get
feedback, it's real feedback.
So they worked on it.
And whenever they
get praise, they
ask the guy to keep up
with his engagement.
Also they're trying to
maximize the ratings.
So what they're doing is
the typical user prompt.
But they don't just
prompt the user whenever.
They look at loyal users
that they prompt first.
They look at prompting them
only when they have good network
coverage, so that they
can actually fill it out.
They have a nice
mechanism in the message
that the user, if they
doesn't want to be bothered
can just click don't
bother me again.
And they will try everything
not to annoy the user.
Because nothing is worse than
being prompted the entire time,
and in the end you're
like, OK, screw that.
I'm going to give
you a one star.
So that's very important.
Also their store listing.
They would never
use spot translators
or Google translate.
They would always use humans.
Because in the end,
that has to be natural.
Store listing experiments
is key ingredient.
Fergus talked to beforehand,
talked about it beforehand.
According to Cameringo,
actually the first time,
they optimized
this entire funnel
or this part of
the funnel, it led
to a 25% increase in downloads.
That's very interesting.
Now we learned about premium.
The next business model
we wanted to look at
was the subscription business.
Because we wanted
to take away this
pay without having seen it.
And wanted to increase
maybe installs.
So we looked at subscriptions.
Now a good friend of mine
explained me the following.
In subscriptions, the
ARPU is straightforward
because it's fixed.
You're having your
monthly, your quarterly,
your annual subscription,
and the rate is fixed.
So you know that beforehand.
The LTV and
subscriptions is really
driven by lifetime,
which is equal to
the average subscription rate.
That again depends
on the renewal rates
that you're having at
the end of the term.
And that again depends on churn.
I hope everybody's following me.
So churn rates and
renewal rates are crucial.
That's why lifetime
here in this example
is 1 divided by churn ratio.
So this changed.
And it's very concrete.
You have to have your
rate or your churn ratio,
which is the opposite
of your renewal rates.
Now ARPU is fixed.
Lifetime is 1 divided
by churn ratio.
What about the
lifetime value period?
Now usually lifetime
value period
should be your average
subscription length.
Because you can
take this assumption
a priority because
you know what's
the average length
because you have this kind
of contextual relationship.
Now in practice, many of the
subscription-based developers
or businesses would
also calculate
based on 180 days
or 365 days, just
like we've seen before in
the example with La Matinale.
There are certain caveats to
calculating lifetime value
for subscription-based apps.
First, exclude free trials.
Those are not revenues
so exclude them.
Second, exclude any form
of promotional introductory
pricing that you might be doing.
Or at least take the
revenue that you're actually
going to get from it.
Secondly, segment by cohorts.
It's worth it to compare the
different lifetimes that you're
actually having.
So the quarterly subscription
versus the annual at least.
Thirdly, discount
future cash flows.
Because you're having
a contractual business,
your lifetime might
be much longer,
hence you need to discount
the net present value.
Fourth, crossplatform
attribution.
Now let's take the example
of a newspaper app.
Your business is
across many platforms.
So you have to be able to
attribute for lifetime value
across those platforms
to compare it.
So that means you
should be measuring,
in the best scenario, with the
same formula on mobile web,
on apps, on desktop.
What's the lifetime value
of the monetization forum
that you're actually using?
Take the formula, do it the
percentage in terms of usage,
and you get an average to
have-- that's like as a basis.
So measurement and
subscription app
LTV equals subscription
fee times churn,
which is subscription fee
times 1 divided by churn.
There is an interesting
paradox for subscription apps.
And I'm not sure how
many of you met it.
And I'm not going to do
a show of hands again.
It's the native churn paradox.
So let's assume my
motorbike app only
has two paying subscribers.
One of them is Maxine,
my colleague here,
who's a biker as well, and
the other is my girlfriend.
Now for whatever reason,
Maxine decides after one year
that he is not going to prolong
his subscription because he's
sick and tired of motorbiking.
So the only customer I
have left is my girlfriend.
Now 50% of my revenue
in theory is gone
and 50% of my users
in theory are gone.
However, I managed to upsell to
super duper extraordinary VIP
package to my
girlfriend for $10 more
than the actual subscription
cost of Maxine was.
I have 50% user
churn, but I have
but I have 110% of revenue.
So that's the native
churn paradox.
You upsell to the users
that are the most engaged
and renew their subscriptions
because you can offer them
additional content that's worth
it for them to pay for it.
And that's what most successful
software services or utilities
apps are actually trying to do.
Upselling to the
users that are core.
Read up on that.
I think it's a very
interesting framework.
We're not going to go deeper
here, but read up on this.
DramaFever.
I talked to a guy at DramaFever.
Korean TV series streaming app.
And they analyze it in
very different cohorts
when it comes to measuring
their lifetime value.
They're looking at user
life, because for them it's
really obvious that there is
a certain moment like after 1
to 2 months of having
subscribed in the app,
this user will stick
around forever.
So they built this
loyalty fairly quickly.
So they will look at
this point of time
when they define their cohorts.
They will also look
after for instance,
churn via payment methods.
Visa debit, Visa
credit, bank debit.
This seems to have an
impact on their measurement.
Think about it if
might have for yours.
And they analyze monthly and
annual passes separately,
because they see a
whole different lifetime
value come around there.
Some other interesting
points for DramaFever,
churn rates are based
on the last three
months, or the average
of the last three months.
They don't take a very
short term metric like one
month, just because of data
reliability and significance.
And they don't take
very long churn rates
because they're changing
the product continuously.
So this will change as well.
Secondly, they calculate
net lifetime value
because they want
to know about cost.
They apply at current rate
going to the net present value,
because of the long cycle.
They're trying not to
spend more than 30% to 40%
of their LTV on custom
acquisition costs.
So this kind of
confirms everything
that I was saying before.
But it's interesting to see
that being put in practice.
Tactics that maximize
lifetime value.
Now I think we've heard
a lot about tactics
to maximize engagement
and retention already.
They are essentially
the same tactics
that you would apply
for LTV, because it's
depending on those variables.
Now for DramaFever,
interestingly free trials
had little to no impact.
On the opposite, it
actually sometimes had
a negative impact, because
a user would download an app
following a specific series.
Now the season would
run out of that series
before the user actually
ever had to pay for the app.
So it backfired very often.
DramaFever also tries to
make their promotions really
impactful.
So they're offering
very few promotions.
But they're making sure that
if they offer promotions,
they are very good promotions
and very appealing to the user.
They offer multiple tiers.
I think many subscription-based
apps do that.
Giving different levels
of access and features
to the different users,
and having different prices
which they test for
any user segment
that they might observe.
As I mentioned before, they're
segmenting quite a lot.
And two very important points.
They're minimizing passive
churn and they're trying
to discourage active churn.
Now passive churn is churn
that users encounter because
of some technical difficulty.
Let's say your credit card has
expired, so you can't renew.
Let's say you don't have
sufficient funds in your bank
account, so you
won't be renewing.
So that's passive churn.
They're trying to have
really proactive custom
service realizing as soon
as there is a complication
and counteracting it.
They're also trying to
discourage active churn, which
is users just choosing not
to renew their subscriptions.
How do they do that?
They put special deals in front
of the user whose subscription
will run out in
the next two weeks,
and try to get him
back into the service.
Next up, freemium.
My pals and I were discussing
and we say all of the games
are kind of doing
it, maybe we should
look into them, in-app purchases
and making some of our content
free and having to
use to pay for others.
Now freemium apps,
LTV it depends
a lot of end user engagement.
And we see again the
survival curve here.
When you talk about
lifetime for freemium apps,
you're taking a slightly
different approach
than with subscriptions.
In the lifetime calculation
for freemium apps,
you're picking reference
dates on the survival curve.
You're picking one day for
instance, 7 days, and 28 days.
You're then looking how
does my historical data
for various user cohorts,
what data points do
I get on those dates, on
those reference dates?
You will get out
an equation which
looks like the one up
there, where p is the day,
and ABC are the coefficients.
Now you will have lots
of various equations.
So as the next
step, you're trying
to get out the accumulative
deviation of those equations
in order to get to an average.
And that average will
be your lifetime.
That sounds a little complex,
but in the end it makes sense.
It's the accurate average
of your lifetime here.
Now your ARPU, that will really
be depending on the units
you sold during a certain
time, the price of the units
you sold.
So the calculation is
total average revenue
in a period divided by
the active users you
have in this period.
Again, look at the
same time units please.
Lastly, the period
usually is a standard.
You're looking at 180 days, or
you're looking the 365 days.
So it's fairly standard
because in the end
you're having very flexible
churn dates, most presumably,
in your non contractual
business model.
So the formula, as we
have it, is the one
that we actually saw
in the very beginning.
LTV period equals
lifetime times ARPU.
OkCupid is one of the biggest
dating apps in Google Play.
They're actually using
two business models.
So it's kind of a
hybrid app, but we're
going to focus on in-app
purchases for them
for the moment.
OkCupid uses an in-house
customized formula.
So we're not really
giving it on that slide,
because it includes both
of those business models.
However, there are certain
variables or certain let's say
factors, that impact how to set
the variables in a crucial way.
First of all, they're looking
at signals that show engagement.
So if a user is in an
active messaging thread,
if he's having conversations
with people in their app,
that's a signal of engagement.
So they would be
looking at those
to define engagement,
retention, and churn rates.
Secondly, they're also
looking at various cohorts.
Again, OkCupid they look for
instance below 35 and above 35
of age, because it shows that
there is major differences
between those user cohorts.
They're also looking
into genders,
and they're also
looking at geographies.
Lastly, they see that churn
levels typically are very high,
but beyond the first usage,
retention gets a lot higher.
So for them, their main job
is to actually get users
over this first
week, because then
that's where they get the
engagement that retains them.
Now when it comes
to maximizing LTV,
OkCupid told us that for
them, optimizing conversions
for in-app purchases mainly
depends on a couple of factors.
First of all, they're trying to
optimize creatives, messaging,
calls to action
in their messages.
On those prompts like
you see here, one of them
they're trying to customize
that into a whole lot of testing
for different cohorts, for
different geographies, genders,
ages, and so on, in order to
get the best possible conversion
rate.
They're also trying to optimize
when they put the prompt based
on the context in which
the user is in right now.
So if you're in a
conversation, or if you're
in the kind of who
visited my profile view,
that's where you get the prompt.
Because that's the
premium functionality,
so they want to sell that.
So that's how they put you
up to the miracle of who
was the person who actually
viewed your profile.
And again, also like
DramaFever beforehand,
they're very selective
with the promotions.
So they will only
offer promotions again,
if they're on high impact.
They typically give either
limited time, 48-hour maximum
to give this kind of
urgency to the user.
Or they do it with
a percentage off,
in terms of 20% as a minimum.
Usually quite
impactful promotions.
With this kind of
testing, OkCupid
claimed that they've increased
20% in purchases for their IPs.
I think I'm going to
speed up a little bit.
Ads.
Ads, everybody's doing it.
So we figured we'd
look into that.
Now "The Guardian" gave us
some interesting insights here.
Typically, they choose one year
as a period for lifetime value
calculation because
it's a good way
to find out if an investment
has actually has an ROI,
and which projects
they should choose
and which they should focus on.
Lifetime is different
for ads monetization,
because generally you're
interested in user impressions.
Because every impression
on every screen
gives you an opportunity
to monetize that user,
as you know.
So retention is important--
but this session like visits,
sessions per visits,
screens per visit,
and so on-- that is really the
key of lifetime calculations.
"The Guardian" has a custom
formula, also in-house
for this, where they essentially
look at those factors.
And they're trying to get
kind of a normal distribution
across all of those
factors in order
to determine their lifetime.
They won't share that formula,
but that's how they do it.
ARPU, again, that's
different here.
Because with ads, as you know,
the price varies quite a lot.
It's based on the sales channel,
direct sales, indirect sales.
The ads [INAUDIBLE].
Is it a native ad?
Is it an interstitial?
It depends on the geographies.
It depends on the buyers.
It depends on the users you're
having, to the audiences,
it depends on the context
of where the ads appear,
and so on and so forth.
So loads of different factors.
Be aware, bring it
down to one price.
That goes without saying.
You have cost per day, cost
per mile, cost per whatever.
Bring it down to
most commonly CPM.
And then fit it
into your equation.
Lifetime value period
maybe 360 days or 180 days
equals lifetime times average
CPM times average number of ads
per month.
Again, that's the simple,
that's a basic formula.
"The Guardian" adapts this one.
Segment by cohorts.
So "The Guardian" usually
takes four different cohorts
for different user segments,
based on loyalty of those users
and the number of
impressions they cost.
Also the cohort, they
segment those cohorts
into the geographies.
And they're using the same
lifetime value calculation
for mobile web and
for apps to compare.
Last model of the day
and then we're done.
That's by the way,
the last model
is also where the bike
gets much more fancy.
So hybrid models are arguably
the most complex models
in life time value calculation
because you combine.
You combine different formulas.
Now many of the apps
and most of the apps
do that because that's
how you maximize it.
You try to have a certain
variety of monetization options
that you give to your
user, because you
want to actually let the user
choose what fits for him,
what works for him or her.
So here you see for
instance, a matrix
that Wooga shared with us.
Popular gaming developer.
Now you can see on the
x-axis, progression
of the player in the game.
And on the y-axis,
the spending level.
Now if a new player
comes in, and he
plays for a very long time,
he ends up in that quadrant.
That quadrant, Wooga will serve
him video interstitial apps
because that's where
they get the best
price as an apps monetizer,
because he never spent a dime
on their in-app purchases.
Now on the other hand,
if there is a new player
installing and downloading,
downloading and installing
the app, and he spends a lot
of money in very early stages,
he will be immediately
offered VIP packages
because that's where games
will try to upsell and include
the user further and further.
That's an interesting model.
And I think it shows
very well, which
user you would want to offer
which kind of monetization.
Now I'm a big fan of
Ultimate Guitar Tabs,
and we had a Hangout with them.
For them, they combine
two business model.
One premium and one
is in-app purchases.
Premium, lifetime
value equals price.
in-app purchases, they are
tiering it down as well.
It's interesting
actually, they told us
that they're having tiers
of $9.99, $7.99, and $2.99,
depending on how long the
user has been having the app.
Paid for it, downloaded, but
only using the basic version.
So the longer you have it,
actually the cheaper it gets.
It's interesting to remember
if any of you play the guitar.
They claim that 40% of
the users are actually
upgrading within the app.
And 65% of their revenues come
from the in-app purchases.
That's an interesting number.
They say that 20% of
their premium upgrades
occur in the on-boarding stage.
So two hours after downloading
and installing the app,
they then get the
VIP branding in.
They give the user an
insight into which content
he will be able to consume
after he paid for the premium
segment.
That increased their in-app
purchase conversion by 53%.
They again also
adjust the prices
per country using those indices
that I mentioned before,
plus 8% in downloads.
And again, store listing,
it's like a message
we're trying to hammer
into your heads.
But store listing experiments
for them is very critical,
localizing the entire funnel
makes them more successful.
14% increase in downloads.
So theory?
Check.
Practices?
Five business models that
I discussed right now.
There's a lot of information.
And for me and my pals, in
developing this app now,
we first have to kind of get
our heads together and think
a little bit what we do
with that information.
Crunch some numbers
in order to be
able to choose which
monetization we want to do,
and where we want to invest
our money, and which segments
we want to invest our money in.
But I think for us and
for you as well, there
are three main takeaways
of that presentation.
First of all, lifetime value
is not an end in itself.
It's not a strategy.
When you calculate lifetime
value, be realistic.
Make sure that you take into
account the cost that you're
actually having, variable cost.
Make sure you're discounting
if you have a long sales cycle.
And make sure that your
cost of acquisition
is at a fairly decent level.
Secondly, the formula.
Lifetime value depends on
your lifetime times your ARPU,
the basis of everything.
Thirdly, and that's where
I have to agree if Nico,
engagement is the new
black because engagement
is the metric that is much
harder to optimize than ARPUs.
So if you get to a high
engagement and high retention,
and a low churn
rate, that's where
you're going to be successful.
So work on that.
And then you optimize
for monetization.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]